per gli altri ragazzi benvenuti questo
video siamo finalmente ritornati sulla
bestia dentro eravamo rimasti al
capitolo 3 vediamo se riesco a
riprendere ceduto come la prima vedevo
vederle con lingue eccolo lì l'ho
colpito colpito l'anomalia non ho capito
dove però non ho capito cos'era ma vabbè
dopo aver distrutto le anomalie ritorna
al punto di prima va bene ci siamo
e adesso orco demonio che brutto spiriti
potenti vi invochiamo vegliate su noi
che stanotte balliamo volti alla luna
alta la fronte
ballano le streghe di gabry ponte per un
su una scala così c'è bellissimo più
l'utilità che veramente mi sto
spaventando sa scala la prendo con
rampino lancia rampino che figata
il fatto che la co t ra bravo a poteri
arrivarci anche tirando con le mani ma
fa niente noi complichiamoci la vita che
bello complicarsi la di roma dove sta
andando la garbata ma tu abiti
esattamente dove che ci sono tutte ste
robe di tua proprietà sta cosa
porca vacca
vedo un qualcosa lì va bene allora cerca
un modo per non mi trasferirei mai in
una casa che intorno a tutte ste cose
cioè va dai un'occhiata prima di
comprarla no vedi che c'è satana non la
comprare oh che bello si vede casa mia
c'è comunque devo dire che ho preso una
casa che è bellissima se non ci fossero
i morti sarebbe veramente figo
c'è una fattoria eccola era quella del
passato l'hanno spostata mazza o hanno
fatto
se con synth e io proprio l'ultima cosa
che farei sarebbe piccard e la fascia
dentro che poi dall'altro è tutto da
capire come funziona e sta roba ceco le
batterie con la cia la carica
dell'iphone non lo sappiamo però
funziona
le anomalie si sono presentate va bene
impulso a vedo che c'è qualcosa lì dove
lo vedo però devo passare di qua una
chiusura incredibile non so come farò ad
aprirla infatti non altro che sta
facendo e c'è qualcuno che è nascosto
qualcosa va bene era una spalla counter
strike signori adesso lo lanciò across
the map faccio una killer
va bene comunque con questa roba uomo sì
sicuramente tagliare la corda nel vero
senso della parola
devo fare lo stesso movimento che fanno
i ragazzi single tutte le sere ok apre
anzi sito solo vedove dove entrare e
anche prima stavo qua cmp per il culo
anche prima ero qui stessa posiziona
perché adesso c'è un altro cancello
ok sempre single nel gol a ecco vedi
cioè cosa ma perché ci sono le scale in
alto sta cosa non la capisco tira cary
grant e poi entrò dal tetto ti passa si
iscriva bene buongiorno è la ha chiesto
tizio salve è un cervo buongiorno
credo che questo non sia un gioco per
vegani però non ne sono sicuro e vero
c'è qualcosa che non è un cervo al neon
pimp my cervo la smetti di lampeggiare
mi dà fastidio porca vacca al cerco con
l'antifurto ci manca solo questo
di sicuro nessuno prova fotter telo è
prono vorrei dirti cose che poi non ci
credi una pace soglie via pia via cesoia
allora le facciamo lavorare se cesoia no
ok ti pensavo di uscire di qua non c'è
un'altra parte proprio perfetto
fammi salire due ore per salire con
sopra perfetto ora buttiamo giusto cervo
o casinò porca vacca che poi
teoricamente a l'avessi saputo prima ti
avrei messo un materasso un sacco di
paglia insomma giusto per non tirare la
testata però va bene c'è qualcosa qua 50
euro
no noto con piacere che hai un petardo
dentro the beast il the beast la bestia
dentro proprio bello show nero lungo
io a mani nude bravo senza i germi
nessuna paura nessuna paura vai poi fai
così senza paura
chissenefrega se detto che schifo che è
bello ragazzi un panino con patatine
fegato cipolla fas chi ti sta uscendo un
pokémon comunque dallo stomaco non so
che cavolo ma di mero subito che era la
dispensa del dei componenti elettrici
cavolo anche io metto i componenti
elettrici del lampadario dentro il mio
cielo in cantina ci siamo ragazzi
abbiamo il fusibile è quindi adesso
posso tornare dentro
la cantina di casa mia infilarlo dove
devo ispirarlo e tutto e tutto funziona
il problema che non ci arriverò mai vivo
alla cantina di casa mia perché prima di
rivelare sicuramente qualcosa succederà
lo scopriremo solo morendo atrocemente
andiamoci comunque sono veramente fiero
di avere una casa dove da almeno non ci
si annoia non ci si annoia casa qua non
c'è neanche bisogno
non abbiamo manco la fibra chissenefrega
tanto c'è il demonio che naviga su
internet con noi quindi va bene la
sveglia non la portiamo a sopportare vai
sveglia sveglia vai vai vai giù prima tu
per favore corrie è tutto tranquillo sia
perfetto arrivo
se mi spunta il demonio ti ammazzo ti
sta col e le lancette del infilo super
hit ecco magari ridotta bene errore
allora andiamo avanti ragazzi
l'importante è riuscire a infilare il
fusibile in tutti i sensi ragazzi tra
l'altro mi ero dimenticato che hanno
murato l'altra parte quindi meraviglioso
trova emma al primo piano sempre che non
esca qualcuno dal muro amore ti ho
portato una cosa molto bella che ho
trovato nella cantina una tanica di
benzina sorelle lavoratore se avessi
sposato lei guarda avrei di questi
problemini sparti il cosplay di
professor layton
va beh questo è un gioco horror signori
benvenuti a imbianchino simulator 2019
recato che non mi posso fare i disegni
che voglio io disegnare i geni
non è più sufficiente per santa inter ma
pensavo stesse pregando i cio devono
avere questo pezzo di fornitura va bene
faccio io
c'è qualcosa qua sotto spero siano 50
euro sono miei se ritrovo è perché sono
io che sto facendo forza su un quadro
c'era un quadro gigantesco tra l'altro
portarlo in cantina bel ragazzo e non è
che era un quadretto era proponeva
attacca così mario schifano in una delle
cose più belle che siano passate da
telemark c'è veramente incredibile
è stato molto bello ovunque trovare un
quadro che 15 non è che dietro a latina
trovi una moneta non trovi la chitarra
quindi non aveva un senso sta cosa però
che cavalca si deve svegliare il
telefono di pomeriggio chiuso rally o
che bella che l'avete fatta la casa ma
dai ma l'avete r nota benissimo
macché
lo farei mille volte bravi dove tenesse
ma non lo vedo non so dove il telefono
equa minchia moderno ma incontrando
iphone 11 hai detto non ce l'abbiamo
ciao david moss è il mio capo più la
madonna non raga ma è bellissimo che
voglio una casa genoa scherzo di note
orribile però che facciamo noi diamo al
computer a si vede è un portatile
bellissimo entra su world of warcraft
non c'è niente nella tazza ma stai
vivendo è vuota faccio io allora due
posizioni 14 posizioni genitore 25
posizione 38 posizione 4 ok 2 14 6 22 va
bene ho capito
chiudi la cover chi da cover 2 14
non sai che perché sto facendo sta roba
prove invece di usare la password
usarono ste cagate pensate se ti
dimentica vila st gaga taqwa quale la
devi rispondere alla domanda come sia la
tua prima maestra quale il nome del tuo
animale domestico vuole cagate ri ecco
qua di esprimere denunciato delle leggi
della fisica quantistica open piece of
cake bene pezzo di torta open de botton
drawer of the device va bene button
drawer porco demonio porco
cosa ci avete nel cervello per fare
queste cagate poi si trova in the
following configuration fg zrt roburent
shock rock house schiuma rioni in questa
gara va bene bellissima presso ha preso
un pezzo di giornale ha visto che c'è
stato in crimine in casa sua e ha detto
se questa è casa mia
quindi ragazzi con quello uguale
episodio to hide and peace inside che
veramente figo lasciate mi piace si
chiede a calare lasciatemi un commento
su cosa ne pensate per me a me
personalmente piace moltissimo
schiacciatasti iscriviti la campanella
prima e ragionati suoi video e noi come
sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video
belle ragazze
[Musica]